[Music]
portrait painting
should transcend photography and there's
a timeless quality about a painting
as opposed to a photographic image of
somebody which is the infinitesimal
snapshot in time whereas a painting you
spend a lot of time with somebody
you get a better feel for the whole
personage
[Music]
the challenge of portraiture is how do
you capture somebody in one image
so when you're with somebody you're
studying them but trying to not make
them feel self-conscious
and you're looking at their gestures the
way they carry themselves their
mannerisms and you try to put that down
on canvas
i try to be very bold with my brush
strokes
and application of paint even though
you're doing a realistic representation
of somebody
it should have texture and build up a
pain and hard and soft edges and
it's that lusciousness of paint i do a
lot of different things but i always
come back to portraiture
because i think it's in many ways the
pinnacle of all the subject matters i do
nlm has an enormous picture collection
and it does include
some formal portraits but the only ones
that are displayed are
people who had really important roles in
the history of the library
it's absolutely fitting that we would
have a portrait of don lindbergh
as one of the major figures in the
development of nleminis services
we're excited about the fact that this
portrait is different from the others
in the inclusion in the portrait of mary
lindbergh
when i first met dr lindberg and mary i
liked him immediately
felt comfortable with them and and that
always makes it nice
for portrait commission because it's as
you can imagine that's not always the
case
mary was very at ease and just kind of
assumed a great pose and i said wow
that's
wonderful and then i was fussing with dr
lindbergh a little bit and
it was okay but i knew it wasn't perfect
and so i was packing up and i happened
to glance up and he was in this pose
that i knew right away that was it
and i said freeze and i got all my
equipment back
out and captured them at that moment
the friends of the national library of
medicine are pleased to present this
portrait as a tribute
to dr and mrs lindbergh when people come
to the library
they'll be able to see this portrait
which truly represents the unique
partnership that dr
and mary lindbergh don and mary as
they're known to many
had as they transformed the library over
the past 30 years
[Music]
you